au bout du sixième ou du septième mois
je le surprends un matin en train de se
masturber sur le balcon
de notre logement
[Musique]
lorsqu'on tombe amoureux on se dit
toujours que c'est pour le meilleur
pourtant eux représentent le pire
petit à petit il tisse une toile autour
de leur victime
ils emprisonnent ceux qui les aiment il
les diminue leur pouvoir de nuisance est
sans limite eux ce sont les pervers
narcissiques Tamara a croisé la route
d'un manipulateur elle commence à peine
à se relever pour Martin c'est une femme
qui a fini par montrer son double
visite Tamara et Martin s'en sont sortis
de justesse mais comment ont-ils réussi
à se reconstruire après avoir connu
l'enfer amoureux
[Musique]
je m'appelle Tamara et je vécu 10 ans
avec un manipulateur narcissique
[Musique]
je m'appelle Martin et j'ai vécu trois
ans avec une perverse narcissique
un jour la route de Tamara et de Martin
croise celle de ses manipulateurs de
l'ombre très vite il se retrouve
totalement sous l'emprise de leur
conjoint respectifs prêt à tout accepter
y compris les pires violences qui payent
laissé leur santé quitte à devenir fou
[Musique]
nous sommes à Courbevoie
à quelques mètres de l'ancien immeuble
de Tamara
c'est prouvant de revenir
là où j'ai vécu 10 ans
c'est mon enfer ici
ça fait longtemps que la jeune femme
n'était pas revenue dans cette ville de
la banlieue parisienne et pour cause
elle a carrément fui son domicile on va
tourner à gauche
on se rapproche là
bien que deux années se soient écoulées
depuis son départ Tamara n'est quand
même pas rassuré à l'approche de son
ancien immeuble
elle tremble de se retrouver nez à nez
avec son ex-conjoint et père de son
enfant
le papa s'il devait le croiser
j'aurais effectivement très peur parce
que quand on a subi
la violence conjugale
on a toujours une peur qui reste
toujours présente
pendant 12 ans Tamara a vécu avec un
manipulateur pervers ou pervers
narcissique dans le langage des
psychiatres
homme parfait en public bourreau en
privé la jeune femme y a laissé sa santé
ses amis son travail
[Musique]
et même la garde de son petit garçon
dans la chambre de timel
c'est une chambre qui est bien rangée
vide
ce qui manque mon enfant
[Musique]
pour échapper à son conjoint Tamara du
s'enfuir à Strasbourg
un choix qui lui a coûté la garde de son
fils
et pourtant son histoire avait débuté
comme un conte de fée
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré mon ex compagnon en 2001
j'ai été séduite par l'homme
charmant bavard
attentionné c'était un bon moment quand
je me souviens de cette période là c'est
super magique nous rencontrent
l'homme à 8 ans de plus que Tamara
issu d'une famille bourgeoise il possède
une excellente éducation un posta
responsabilité pour elle c'est l'omideal
on va là on n'arrive pas à séparer et
c'est comme ça que notre histoire
commence et d'ailleurs elle est très
fusionnelle puisqu'en même pas trois
mois j'atterris dans son appartement
il semble coller parfaitement à l'idéal
de la jeune fille mais en réalité son
prince charmant possède une double
personnalité
[Musique]
vous êtes psychologue clinicienne et
auteur de la manipulation ordinaire on
emploie de plus en plus le terme pervers
narcissique il s'affiche même à la Une
de certains magazines est-ce qu'on
devient pervers narcissique ou est-ce
qu'on est comme ça on ne n'est pas comme
ça c'est une structure de personnalité
qui se met en place dans l'enfance parce
que ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
développé un apprentissage des jeux de
pouvoir entre les gens de manière telle
qu'elle puisse négocier et ne pas avoir
ce besoin de dominer tout le temps
l'autre est-ce que c'est une maladie non
ce n'est pas une maladie c'est une
structure de personnalité je dirais un
peu tordue certes mais qui est
construite librement alors comment le
pervers arrive à manipuler sa victime
ils ne s'en rend pas compte c'est quand
même très important de dire que cette
instinctif quand on demande si c'est
conscient ou inconscient je crois que la
meilleure réponse c'est de dire que
cette instinctif ça lui paraît normal de
contrôler l'autre personne
dans le cas de Tamara dans un premier
temps son mari paraît être l'homme idéal
oui alors dans les relations de couple
un symptôme qui est très fréquent ce
sont des relations qui démarrent très
très vite et qui donne une impression
d'idéale dès le début ce qui est
frappant dans les deux histoires c'est
que les protagonistes se sont rencontrés
par internet c'est à dire hors d'un
milieu affectif ou amical qui introduit
progressivement la relation et qui
permet de sentir si la personne nous
convient ou pas donc ici on démarre
immédiatement dans un processus de
séduction et donc les gens sont sécurité
je dirais relationnels se lancent dans
une relation qui leur paraît idéalisée
mais il y a toujours quelque chose de
suspect dans le fait que une relation
démarre sur les chapeaux de roue ça veut
dire que le pervers narcissique vérifie
s'il la victime peut tomber dans son
emprise
oui la victime n'est pas à ce moment-là
encore
défini comme victime par la personne qui
est plutôt perverse
elle teste la relation et elle sent si
elle peut petit à petit développer une
emprise sur cette personne si elle ne se
rebiffe pas si elle est conciliante
alors la relation se poursuit
[Musique]
trois mois après leur rencontre Tamara
s'installe avec l'élu de son cœur
mais le rêve va se fissurer quand la
jeune femme découvre la vraie nature de
son ami
[Musique]
à 36 ans Martin a lui aussi connu
l'enfer auprès d'une compagne perverse
narcissique
une histoire qui a failli le détruire
là on est sur la Grand-Place
et c'est ici que j'ai rencontré
Charlotte
c'est sur Internet que Martin rencontre
Charlotte celle qui allait faire de sa
vie un cauchemar mais à l'époque où la
jeune femme le contact il est à des
années lumières d'imaginer ce qui se
cache derrière son visage d'ange
ici
ça c'est assez rigolo qu'on soit face à
cette affiche qui est là
[Musique]
presque
comme si c'était pas par hasard en fait
pendant trois ans Martin va vivre sous
le contrôle total et absolu d'une femme
qui va s'avérer être un véritable tyran
dans l'intimité
pourtant son premier rendez-vous Martin
s'en souvient comme si c'était hier
elle était très séduisante elle était
très bien maquillée bien habillée elle
avait des jolis yeux verts et
j'étais vraiment sous le charme et je me
suis dit cette fille c'est une perle
le mot est bien
chouette dès les premières minutes
Martin est éblouie par la jeune femme
chose étrange cependant alors qu'il se
connaissent à peine Charlotte lui confie
des détails très intimes de son passé
alors elle m'a tout de suite annoncé
quand on a pris notre premier verre
qu'elle avait une enfance difficile et
notamment qu'elle avait été battue par
son père
et dans la foulée elle m'a annoncé
également qu'elle avait été battue par
son ancien conjoint
et ça ça a tout de suite déclencher ma
fibre protectrice
malgré ses étonnantes révélations Martin
est sous le charme il est persuadé
d'avoir mis la main sur un véritable
trésor un trésor qu'il faut absolument
protéger
c'est un personnage qui en jette elle
est aussi très jolie et très charmante
en fait donc elle me plaît tout de suite
physiquement elle me plaît pour ce
qu'elle est et si tout ce qu'elle me dit
est vrai voilà je signe tout de suite
mais le jeune homme va très vite
s'apercevoir qu'il commet une grave
erreur
[Musique]
deux jours après leur première rencontre
les deux amoureux ne se quittent plus
la même un petit studio ici à
l'avant-dernière étage et ça faisait pas
très longtemps qu'elle habitait là ça
faisait peut-être un mois ou deux donc
elle avait très très peu de meubles
elle avait même pas de lit en fait elle
avait juste un matelas au sol
pas grand chose en fait c'était quand
même le début heureux de notre histoire
parce que c'est là où il faisait le plus
d'efforts pour être le plus agréable
possible avec moi et
à partir du moment où elle a quitté cet
appartement
c'était plus du tout la même Charlotte
qui vivait avec moi
et deux mois à peine après leur
rencontre sur la Grand-Place charlotte
va montrer son véritable visage
[Musique]
Geneviève Schmitt vous êtes spécialiste
de l'aide aux victimes et vous-même
ancienne victime d'un pervers
narcissique on entend beaucoup parler
d'hommes mais on se rend compte avec
l'histoire de Martin qu'il existe aussi
des femmes perverses effectivement il y
a des femmes pervers narcissiques et
j'ai de plus en plus de d'hommes qui
viennent maintenant vers moi comment un
pervers narcissique parvient-il à créer
cette emprise sur sa victime
le pervers narcissique crée une emprise
sur la victime mais la victime aussi va
chercher le manipulateur pervers il y a
une sorte de réaction comme une réaction
chimique qui se passe entre les deux on
dit souvent que la victime tombe dans le
piège etc mais bon il faut aussi se
rendre compte que la victime cherche en
quelque sorte la personnalité qui va
correspondre à ses besoins alors vous
êtes vous-même passer par là on se rend
vraiment compte de rien quand ça se met
en place à l'instant où j'ai croisé le
regard de celui qui allait me faire
connaître cette expérience j'ai su qu'il
y avait un danger ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai retrouvé souvent dans les
expériences qui ont été retransmises par
les patients ce sentiment de trouble et
en même temps une envie une envie
furieuse auquel on ne résiste pas
s'empêcher d'aller vers ce piège et très
souvent on se leur on se dit oui mais je
l'aime donc mon amour va permettre de
passer au-delà de ces réticences et
voilà c'est le piège est fermé quoi
à 22 ans Tamara pensait avoir trouvé
l'homme parfait mais au bout de six mois
elle découvre l'autre facette de celui
qu'elle aime
à commencer par son goût pour le
voyeurisme
on s'est installé un peu près trois
quatre mois après
nous être rencontrés et au bout du
sixième ou du 7e mois je le surprends un
matin en train de se masturber sur le
balcon
de notre logement
[Musique]
je suis choquée je me dispute avec lui
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi il a
fait ça et je comprends pas je me prends
ma je prends une claque
après cette première gifle tamara est
terriblement choquée
elle pense tout de suite quitter son
compagnon
contre toute attente l'homme réussit à
retourner la situation à son avantage
il m'a dit que c'était son passé que
parfois on pouvait faire des choses un
peu saugrenu
que ça faisait partie de la de la vie de
couple aussi voilà des choses normales
donc moi monsieur effectivement poser
des questions et puis en fin de compte
je me rends compte que au final c'est
moi qui culpabilise quoi de début de
conversation ou je trouve que c'est lui
qui a un problème au final je me
retrouve à la dernière phrase assez moi
qui a un problème et
au milieu il y a eu beaucoup de blabla
il y a eu deux heures et au final et ben
on a on est plus à l'origine de la
conversation
[Musique]
tamara est persuadé de ne pas être à la
hauteur de celui qu'elle aime
faut dire qu'en quelques mois de vie
commune son compagnon a entamé une
véritable entreprise de destruction
mentale
[Musique]
et moi je l'ai vécu dans tous les sens
du terme tel qu'une merde
après c'est la dévalorisation de sa
propre image tu vaux rien tout ce que tu
fais tout ce que tu fais et nul tu sais
pas faire la cuisine
le regard comment est repasser ma
chemise voilà c'est des petites choses
comme ça et puis après ça devient de
temps en temps conasse [__]
harcelé moralement Tamara perd peu à peu
l'appétit et maigri à vue d'œil
bon après je peux me regarder dans un
miroir je pouvais plus manger donc j'ai
perdu l'appétit
[Musique]
je voulais manger
une gourmande et je pouvais plus j'avais
des noob ventre
[Musique]
ces troubles du comportement alimentaire
le compagnon de Tamara va s'en servir
pour asseoir son emprise il va la
persuader qu'elle est anorexique et la
convaincre de quitter son travail
[Musique]
pour Martin aussi tout est allé très
vite
crois-moi à peine après leur première
rencontre Charlotte quitte son petit
studio pour s'installer chez lui
mais à peine arrivé la jeune femme
commence à se montrer tyrannique
en fait toute cette décoration c'est
c'est Charlotte qui s'en est
occupé parce qu'en fait quand elle est
arrivée ici il fallait absolument tout
refaire donc on a on a jeté tous les
meubles à la poubelle elle m'a elle m'a
forcé à tout virer et puis au fur et à
mesure on a on a refait tout à son
groupe
Martin a beau cédé à tous les caprices
de celles qu'il aime les crises
commencent la première dispute éclate
brutalement lors d'un dîner au
restaurant ce soir là elle elle me
dévisage et me dit mais tu me fais la
tête qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qui va pas
alors qu'il y avait rien qui n'allait
pas j'étais content d'être là au
restaurant avec elle ou tout se passait
bien a priori
et là pendant toute la durée du repas
elle va m'insulter elle va me dire que
j'en ai rien à faire d'elle et elle va
elle va pas me lâcher pendant toute la
durée du repas
et une fois qu'on sort du restaurant
elle va me hurler dessus en sortant du
restaurant elle va m'insulter
et en fait on marche cette pire en pire
elle me hurle dessus elle me traite de
tous les noms et à un moment donné elle
me prend par le col de chemise et elle
ne secoue et elle me déchire en fait la
chemise tellement elle a fait ça que
violence et ça ça a duré peut-être deux
heures
et après c'est un peu calmé et puis
et puis c'était tout
après cet épisode Martin est désemparé
mais chaque fois qu'elle va trop loin
Charlotte arrive à inverser la situation
en se posant comme victime
des crises ça se terminait en pleurs de
sa part en me disant tu vas me quitter
tu vas me quitter j'étais toujours à
deux doigts de partir en disant mais
c'est c'est invivable d'être comme ça et
à chaque fois je me disais mais il faut
qu'elle se fasse soigner et peut-être
que je peux l'aider je me sentais
responsable d'elle je me sentais
responsable de son
de sa survie de son bien-être parce que
et même de sa survie ça se justifie bien
parce que en fait il était tellement
instable qu'elle pouvait faire n'importe
quoi elle pouvait elle pouvait avoir des
réactions mais complètement
disproportionné et faire vraiment des
choses qui sont
extrêmement dangereuses
quel est ton colère charlotte est
capable de tout briser dans la maison
avant de s'auto mutiler sous les yeux de
son compagnon
la veille des fiançailles charlotte est
entré dans une crise pas possible
[Musique]
elle m'en voulait vraiment
à mort parce que j'étais pas là à
l'heure qu'il fallait
[Musique]
un moment donné elle a donné un grand
coup de pied dans la porte son pied est
passé à travers le la ville la vitre
elle saignait elle avait une entaille
assez importante au tibia
malgré cette violence extrême Martin va
quand même se fiancer avec la jeune
femme qu'il aime depuis six mois
Marion Anderson on se demande pourquoi
Tamara et Martin ne quitte pas leur
conjoint dès les premiers signes de
violence c'est évidemment le conseil
qu'on devrait donner à toutes les
personnes qui ressentent ces premiers
signes mais ce qui se passe souvent
c'est que ce sont des personnes qui sont
dans une soif d'amour de reconnaissance
qui est un petit peu excessive et donc
elle se rendent sourde et aveugles au
premier signe en plus l'emprise est un
phénomène qui s'installe progressivement
et donc la balance entre les bons
moments et les mauvais moments et
pendant les premiers mois très positifs
et c'est encore plus dur d'accepter de
se dire que finalement on peut prendre
du plaisir dans cette relation
je ne sais pas si on peut vraiment si
les victimes vont reconnaître qu'elle
ressentent du plaisir mais
paradoxalement c'est une forme de
plaisir un petit peu masochiste
c'est-à-dire que ça donne une forme de
d'intensité à leur existence elles sont
habitées par quelque chose de très très
important qui est ce jeu de passion
destruction qui les obsède dont elle
parle éventuellement ou dont elle ne
parle pas mais qui occupe intensément
leur vie et c'est cette intensité qui
peut-être leur manquait donc pour qu'une
relation avec un pervers narcissique
fonctionne il faut que les deux
personnes aient quelque part une
personnalité défaillante
oui effectivement les victimes
n'acceptent pas l'idée et on peut le
comprendre à hauteur de la souffrance
qu'elle vive elle n'accepte pas l'idée
qu'elles sont d'une certaine manière
complice de leur partenaire bourreaux or
c'est malheureusement le cas parce que
effectivement il y a des tas de gens qui
ne supporteraient pas de reprendre une
relation après s'être fait insulté ou
battre etc donc ce sont des gens qui ont
un manque de confiance en eux qui est
criant
au fil des mois le compagnon de Tamara
prend de plus en plus de pouvoir sur
elle d'autant qu'il alterne violence
avec gestes de tendresse inattendu à
chaque fois qu'il y a une crise où on
est tombé très bas
il me fait des supers cadeaux quoi il me
dit qu'il m'aime et qu'on va s'en sortir
[Musique]
je l'aime encore et il n'y a pas que
Tamara qui soit sous emprise son
conjoint a également réussi à séduire
son entourage
quitte à se faire passer pour un croyant
auprès d'une communauté de chrétiens où
la jeune femme s'est réfugiée pour
prendre du recul
ce monsieur va se mettre à faire la
lave-vaisselle de 40 personnes alors
c'est pas son cas il va se lever pour
aller au lODES les lODES c'est la prière
le matin à 5h30 du matin c'est un lève
tard ça a jamais été son cas
il va faire le bénédicité le bénédicile
c'est le bénédicité c'est la prière
avant le repas Tamara sent bien que son
conjoint est en train de jouer la
comédie elle commence à perdre son
sang-froid
je décide d'aller faire une pause clope
à côté dehors ce monsieur me rejoint il
me regarde avec un regard j'ai gagné tu
vois je les ai mis dans mes poches quoi
et du coup je m'énerve je monte en ton
et là il y a le berger de la communauté
qui intervient bien mais Tamara tu vois
c'est toi qui a un problème tu es
anorexique et donc voilà la situation
est inversée là je sens que j'ai perdu
mes amis que je connais depuis 20 ans
sans travail sans argent Tamara se
retrouve désormais sans allier son
conjoint s'est octroyé le rôle d'un
homme parfait au détriment de la jeune
femme on voit un homme qui travaille qui
ramène des sous à la maison qui montre
qui s'occupe bien de son enfant puisque
devant les autres il va remonter la
chaussette qui est descendue
il va se montrer en très bon père et moi
toute fragile toute cassée qui a été
super abîmée par la violence conjugale
on me voit
on me voit presque en sa larmes pour mon
état et ils ont raison mais il se pose
pas les bonnes questions ils vont pas
plus loin
ironie du sort c'est le bourreau qui
endosse l'image de la victime du coup
les proches de Tamara se détournent
d'elle
la marraine de mon fils que je connais
depuis plus de 20 ans et maintenant en
contact avec ce monsieur et moi elle
veut plus du tout me parler alors que
c'est une amie que je connais depuis 20
ans et elle me manque beaucoup
pour la jeune femme c'est la double
peine en plus d'être maltraité plus
personne ne la croit
[Musique]
malgré les crises de plus en plus
fréquentes Martin et Charlotte se
fiancent pour leur entourage le couple
vit un bonheur sans nuage tout s'ignore
qu'à huis clos l'histoire d'amour vire
au cauchemar sa compagne exige d'avoir
le contrôle total et absolu de ses
moindres faits et gestes
[Musique]
elle voulait contrôler déjà intégralité
de mes communications donc mes mails ou
plus facilement les SMS les coups de
téléphone donc mon téléphone comme ça ça
la dérangé au plus haut point j'avais
pour habitude de le mettre en silencieux
le week-end et de faire en sorte de ne
pas répondre aux appels
évite Martin devient injoignable pour
ses proches désormais il vivra
pratiquement coupé du monde
[Musique]
les copains qui téléphonent et qui m'ont
jamais au bout du fil
après il commence à prendre un peu de
distance ça c'est normal
j'étais avant très joignable tout le
temps disponible je deviens beaucoup
moins je deviens beaucoup moins parce
que il faut qu'elle soit au centre de
mon attention et si jamais je veux voir
les copains c'est avec elle
toute la bonne volonté du jeune homme ne
semble pas calmer les angoisses de
Charlotte elle veut étendre encore plus
son emprise alors pour la satisfaire
Martin va également abandonner ses
loisirs
[Musique]
les pervers sont tout pour que leur
conjoint s'isole coupe les ponts avec
leur entourage c'est une étape
incontournable c'est un processus très
très fréquent d'isoler sa victime parce
que c'est une manière de l'affaiblir
bien entendu d'empêcher les témoins de
voir quoi que ce soit et aussi surtout
parce que le pervers narcissique ne
supporte pas que la personne qu'il aime
puisse aimer ailleurs même si c'est un
parent frère une sœur parce que pendant
ce temps-là sa victime n'est pas centrée
sur lui donc c'est vraiment on voit là
on voit bien que c'est une problématique
narcissique et toujours dans le cadre de
ce narcissisme se pervers fait toujours
en sorte de passer pour quelqu'un de
bien en société quelqu'un de normal oui
c'est indispensable qu'il passe pour
quelqu'un de bien et même de très très
bien parce que ça renforce son
narcissisme c'est pour ça qu'on trouve
de nombreuses personnalités pervers
narcissiques à des hauts postes pour de
pouvoir en politique dans l'entreprise
dans les médias parce que ce sont des
lieux où leur nourriture narcissique est
importante est-ce que le pervers
narcissique a une limite à sa perversion
alors pour dire les choses simplement ce
ne sont pas les pervers narcissiques les
plus violents qui sont les plus pénibles
pour les partenaires parce que leur
violence est tellement évidente qu'on
peut plus vite sans défaire les
personnalités les plus destructrices sur
le plan psychique sont les pervers
narcissiques à petite dose qui reste je
dirais habillé d'une
façade tout à fait cordiale courtoise
normale mais qui manipule de façon
sournoise et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour les victimes de prendre
conscience du processus de destruction
psychique qui se met en place au goutte
à goutte
[Musique]
depuis sa rupture il y a un an Martin a
retrouvé les joies du VTT son sport
favori
c'est quelque chose que je pouvais plus
faire du temps de Charlotte parce que
simplement
elle
ne supportait pas que je puisse partir
sans elle et surtout que je puisse
m'amuser que je puisse faire du sport
c'est quelque chose qui me plaisait donc
qui ne lui plaisait pas
Martin avait l'habitude de s'entraîner
tous les dimanches avec son ami Jean
Albert salut
[Musique]
les deux hommes se connaissent depuis
près de 10 ans
Jean Albert est un des rares à avoir
remarqué que quelque chose clochait dans
la vie de son ami
et il était pollué par les sms il
passait sa vie il était sans arrêt
perturber il devait répondre par SMS
envoyer bien que ça le même ça le
plaisait pas que ça l'embêtait je me
suis posé des questions quand j'ai vu
qu'effectivement peler les ponts pour ne
soyez plus on pouvait plus faire
moi-même de vélo ensemble par exemple ça
devenait vraiment très difficile
Jean Albert ne peut que constater la
disparition de son vieil ami mais il
n'imagine pas ce qu'il vit
il y en a pas parlé
pas donc c'est quand même il était
vraiment vraiment renfermé
en réalité à cette époque Martin vit
entièrement pour sa fiancée au fur et à
mesure des mois les crises monte en
puissance tous les prétextes sont bons
je vais me brosser les dents et je mets
plus que une minute trente alors
peut-être pas une minute 30 précisément
mais ça dure trop longtemps en fait et
ça c'est impossible pour elle que je
passe du temps à me brosser les dents
trop de temps
quand Charlotte se met en colère c'est
hurlement peuvent durer des heures sans
que Martin puisse trouver d'échappatoire
à sa violence
[Musique]
désormais sans travail et sans revenu
tamara est totalement à la merci de son
manipulateur de compagnon
ma famille est loin j'ai perdu mon
travail enfin j'ai perdu j'ai donné ma
démission j'ai plus d'argent j'ai aucune
entrée monsieur me donne que des
sous-gouttes à gouttes donc je peux pas
prévoir de partir je peux pas mettre de
côté
[Musique]
mais après des années de calvaire Tamara
et tabou en 2006 elle réussit à fuir une
fois de plus et se réfugier à Lisieux
tout de suite moi j'ai mis en place psy
nutritionniste enfin tous les moyens
étaient pour moi important pour pour
réussir en fait à sortir de l'emprise
[Musique]
comment tu vas
Stéphanie et nutritionniste c'est elle
qui suit Tamara à l'époque dès le
premier rendez-vous elle comprend tout
de suite que la jeune femme n'est pas
anorexique
pour être catalogué d'anorexique faut
remplir un certain nombre de critères
que tamaron ne remplit pas donc déjà
d'un point de vue purement théorique
elle rentrait pas dans les critères de
l'anorexie mentale telle qu'elle est
définie
le diagnostic de Stéphanie est sans
appel Tamara n'est pas malade elle ne va
pas bien à cause de sa relation
amoureuse
[Musique]
enfin moi je voyais vraiment une
progression et à chaque fois une
dégringolade c'est à dire que c'était tu
ne vas pas t'en sortir quoi c'était un
peu comme si le message qui lui
renvoyait c'était ça c'était une tu ne
pourras jamais t'en sortir sans moi
peut-être un petit peu dans cette idée
là quoi donc ton petit chemin que tu
mènes à Lisieux sans moi je viens et je
casse la baraque quoi je te ramène je te
ramène à zéro quoi tous les week-ends
son compagnon vient frapper à la porte
de Tamara au bout d'un an elle finit par
céder à ses promesses elle rentre à
Courbevoie et tombe enceinte dans la
foulée mais dès le 8ème mois de
grossesse la face sombre de son conjoint
va refaire surface
[Musique]
Geneviève Schmidt Tamara prononce un mot
intéressant elle dit que son conjoint a
été un caméléon cette emblématique du
pervers narcissique il va s'adapter à la
situation dans laquelle il se trouve à
manipulateur par exemple celui que j'ai
connu avec sa mère avait un comportement
manipulateur certes mais différent
qu'avec ça son fils qu'avec ses
collègues qu'avec moi il y a quel moment
la victime a le déclic à quel moment
elle décide de s'en sortir
il y en a qui ne décide jamais il y en a
qui les décide parce qu'il y a eu la
chose en trop
la violence en trop ou alors parce que
j'ai plusieurs patients d'ailleurs
femmes sont les enfants qui ont demandé
par fulls
sur mon nez victime si on décide de s'en
sortir comment est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'il y a
des méthodes est-ce qu'il y a des
endroits pour être aidé une fois qu'on a
compris qu'on était là-dedans et qu'on a
décidé de sortir c'est pas encore si
simple on prend pas la porte et on s'en
va ça marche pas comme ça parce qu'elle
se phénomène d'emprise où on revient
quand même et c'est comme ces femmes
battues qui qui reviennent ou les
enfants qui reviennent vers leurs
parents tortionnaires
pour les victimes appelaient ça de
l'amour c'est pas de l'amour c'est de
l'addiction comme on est addict à la
cocaïne ou à tout ce qu'on veut on
revient parce qu'il y a un manque
toute la perversion elle est là je pense
que la victime en tout cas c'est que
c'est la victime sait qu'elle est dans
un système qui l'a tue elle est dans un
système vraiment toxique au plus haut
point mais va revenir quand même
[Musique]
pour Martin le cauchemar semble sans fin
les crises de sa fiancée sont de plus en
plus fréquentes elles peuvent durer des
nuits entières
elle était très violente dans ses propos
et également violente
physiquement en fait
elle me bousculait elle faisait en sorte
si je me m'isolais dans une pièce de
devenir de tambouriner à la porte ce que
je m'étais enfermé et
elle était prête à tout casser pour
empêcher Martin de partir Charlotte
n'hésite pas à lui confisquer ses
papiers et ses clés de voiture il se
retrouve régulièrement pris au piège
obligé de supporter ses crises
et à plusieurs reprises ou elle s'est
mis dans une dans des colères pas
possible m'a donné des coups de pied et
j'ai eu une mauvaise réaction en fait et
je lui ai mis des baffes et une fois que
je lui avais mis une paire de baffes en
fait
la tension retombée elle était calmée
elle était en pleure assise par terre en
pleurs et c'était terminé la crise était
passée
pour ceux de le pousser dans ces
derniers retranchements charlotte a
atteint son objectif
faire de son fiancé un homme en colère
elle avait gagné elle avait eu ce retour
de violence qu'elle cherchait chez moi
elle allait puiser au plus profond de
moi il fallait qu'elle me qu'elle me
mitraille d'insultes il fallait qu'elle
me donne des coups pour que je réagisse
et parfois peut-être cinq fois sur sur
les trois ans elle a réussi à les
chercher quelque chose chez moi qui que
je pensais pas être présent le jeune
homme se retrouve alors pris dans un
[Musique]
cercle je me sentais coupable mais je me
sentais coupable comme pas possible je
culpabilisais je me sentais mal je me
dis mais c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
impossible c'est c'est
ignoble et elle avait réussi ce qu'elle
voulait plus Martin culpabilise plus
Charlotte prend le pouvoir le jeune
homme est pris au piège
d'autant que sa fiancée alterne violence
épreuve d'amour touchante
ça c'est le faire-part de mariage et
c'est un faire-part qu'elle avait
réalisé entièrement à la main c'est des
petits noeuds c'est des petites strasses
et des petits
voilà déjà c'est très enfantin et c'est
également
elle doit être vraiment amoureuse folle
pour réaliser un tel faire-part en fait
des faire-part comme celui-ci Charlotte
en confectionnera plus de 50 entièrement
à la main
mais à trois semaines du mariage coup de
théâtre la jeune femme va réserver une
dernière surprise à son fiancé
[Musique]
depuis la naissance de son enfant le
conjoint de Tamara est de plus en plus
violent
donc là il est devenu plus que méchant
plus que dangereux j'avais plus la
double personnalité et là pour parce que
j'avais peur de pas être cru parce qu'il
me menaçait il me dit je vais te faire
interner tu vas voir tu pourras pas tu
pourras pas t'en sortir
on te croira jamais jamais jamais
[Musique]
seulement cette fois la jeune femme veut
protéger son fils lorsque celui-ci a
deux ans elle s'enfuit avec lui à
Strasbourg une décision qui lui coûtera
très cher on voit ce monsieur stable
propriétaire non appartement
poser
au tribunal et il me décrit comme une
anorexique
ou au départ en plus je peux pas nier
parce que j'arrive j'arrive à Strasbourg
je joue hyper creuse fragile et donc
tout fait que quand on me regarde moi si
on regarde que l'étiquette sont cherché
plus loin on se dit c'est vrai elle a
anorexique elle est fragile
[Musique]
à l'époque du jugement Tamara vient en
foyer d'accueil avec son petit garçon et
elle n'a pas de travail le tribunal
tranche en faveur du père de l'enfant
malgré une condamnation pour violence
conjugale
ça
c'est la condamnation de Monsieur
à l'ensemble de ses papiers ça fait
trois mois avec sur 6 avec une amende de
590 euros relevé de condamnation pénale
trois mois avec sursis
violence conjugale
cette pièce a bien été versée dans le
dossier de Tamara mais cela n'a pas
suffi depuis un an la jeune maman doit
se contenter des vacances scolaires pour
serrer le petit garçon dans ses bras
[Musique]
Laura inker vous êtes avocat spécialiste
en droit pénal et en droit des personnes
mais vous êtes également le président de
l'Observatoire européen des violences
intrafamiliales c'est très très
compliqué pour une victime de faire
reconnaître qu'elle est maltraitée
moralement c'est un combat qui dure
depuis des années c'est très difficile
pour les violences physiques c'est
relativement
facile aujourd'hui parce que le
traumatisme physique se voit pour le
traumatisme psychologique ou le harcelon
oral c'est beaucoup plus compliqué parce
que c'est un traumatisme qui ne se voit
pas d'emblée et donc il faut un certain
discernement une certaine formation et
comment est reconnu la violence morale
d'un point de vue pénal d'un peu du
pénal c'est un délit aujourd'hui
punissable d'une peine de prison et
d'une peine d'amande ce qu'il y a des
cas de condamnation pour violence
psychologique est-ce que vous avez des
exemples il y a très peu de
condamnations ou alors c'est des
condamnations combinées quand vous avez
à la fois du harcèlement téléphonique et
ça le bâtiment facile à prouver et que
vous avez en plus de la dégradation
physique la personne en colère a cassée
un meuble on va poursuivre sur la base
de du harcèlement téléphonique voir de
la dégradation du matériel et
accessoirement sur le harcèlement moral
mais sur le harcèlement moral en soi il
y a pratiquement pas eu de condamnation
[Musique]
à quelques semaines du mariage le couple
de Martin va de plus en plus mal mais
toujours très amoureux de sa fiancée le
jeune homme s'accroche pour lui faire
plaisir il décide de l'emmener en
vacances à Nice ou la jeune femme a vécu
avant de s'installer à Lille
c'est très bizarre parce que dès le
départ en fait je sens qu'il y a quelque
chose qui va pas et en fait à peine
arrivé là-bas
le jour où on arrive
ça y est elle ne m'aime plus
elle me regarde plus elle
me montre le l'endroit où elle a quitté
son ancien conjoint
et elle m'annonce qu'elle me quitte donc
là je viens fou je sais plus je sais
plus voilà moi je suis complètement
dépité et elle ce qu'elle va faire en
fait elle va s'acheter des habits
nouvelle vie nouvelle tenue donc elle
fait les magasins elle s'achète une
tenue elle demande à la passer tout de
suite en fait donc elle change
complètement son habit
Charlotte disparaît de la vie de Martin
du jour au lendemain sans laisser
d'adresse et presque sans explication le
jeune homme ne comprend plus rien
quand elle est partie et moi je me suis
retrouvé
je me suis retrouvé très mal vide de
tout vide de elle était elle était plus
là c'était mon centre d'intérêt mon
centre de vie elle était plus là et
j'avais plus d'autres
j'avais presque tout perdu quand elle
est partie et je me suis retrouvé tout
seul
l'explication de ces trois ans d'enfer
c'est en surfant sur Internet que Martin
va la trouver
en montant les différents sites les
différents forums j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé un ensemble d'éléments qui
m'ont fait sortir le le terme fatal de
pervers narcissique et donc j'ai regardé
pas mal de pas mal de sites là dessus
j'ai regardé des émissions
j'ai regardé j'ai même acheté des livres
sur le sujet et je me suis rendu compte
que c'était exactement le le
comportement de Charlotte
ce diagnostic établit Martin peut
commencer à faire le deuil de son
histoire
[Musique]
petit à petit Tamara commence à se
reconstruire et retrouve même le plaisir
d'avoir une vie sociale
[Musique]
après l'isolement bah oui on est
tellement cassé on croit plus en rien ni
à l'amour niant l'amitié donc on se dit
j'ai plus de cœur je veux plus aimer
l'amour c'est plus pour moi et
il y a une amie qui me dit ne dit jamais
jamais il ne faut jamais dire jamais et
puis un jour quand ça vous arrive c'est
voilà on savoure quoi
aujourd'hui Tamara se réalimente
normalement elle a déjà repris 6 kg mais
surtout elle est fière du chemin
parcouru elle ne sera plus jamais
victime
tout ce qui m'a enlevé je veux le
reprendre il m'a volé des choses mon
objectif c'est de les reprendre et lui
dire tu vois tu as peut-être la guerre
de mon fils mais mes amis là à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui tu les auras pas c'est
précieux et mon bonheur
à part
[Musique]
Martin est aussi sur la voie de la
guérison un an et demi s'est écoulé
depuis le départ de Charlotte Martin n'a
jamais su ce qui était devenu son
ex-fiancé la jeune femme s'est évanouie
dans la nature sans laisser la moindre
trace après avoir relaté son histoire
sur un blog Martin s'est découvert une
vocation d'écrivains
il envisage même d'écrire un scénario
basé sur son histoire
ça m'a permis d'avoir en écrivant tout
ça dans un bloc d'avoir des retours de
personnes qui avaient vécu à peu près la
même chose et qui m'ont fait des
commentaires assez positifs sur sur le
fait que ce que j'écrivais c'était
c'était très censé c'était il y avait
pas de haine dans ce que j'écrivais et
il y a des personnes qui m'ont dit mais
quand on vous lit on a simplement
l'impression que vous êtes quelqu'un de
bon qui s'est juste fait avoir